there were a number of
comments from people
that the buyback was much more expensive
than they thought and some of them had
mistaken assumptions on what they were
supposed to be paying others
we're not sure what happened so I've
invited the retirement system to tell us
how they're doing those calculations and
what if anything has changed since any
and that we will not I hope we will not
be going off on to a lot of other issues
because
we need to cover this one specific
question
thank you my name is Mark Cavanaugh I'm
interim Chief legal counsel for the
um not sure if you wanted to give me a
me to give a brief overview we just want
to ask questions or
how do you want to proceed start with a
brief overview so we know which
questions to ask okay so SB 363
provides that certain group two members
who were in that middle tier
of members who were employed on 112 but
did not have 10 years of service
and For Whom the minimum years of
service and age of retirement were
gradually increase based on how many
years of service they had at that time
this bill would allow the member to buy
back as many years of service necessary
to get them to
uh be able to retire at age 45 and uh 20
years of service as was the law before
2012.
the law requires that the member paid
the full Actuarial cost of the years of
service
they can buy uh years of service in
increments of a year at a time no
partial years and based on how many
years of service they had on 112 they
can buy between one and four years of
service whatever is necessary to either
reduce
their years of service
or add to the as a service to get to the
uh to be able to retire to the 20 or 8
or to get their age to 45 whichever they
need and some people need the age some
people need the service
the full Actuarial cost is composed of
three elements the largest is the fact
that the members will be retiring
earlier and receiving their pension for
more years that makes up about
two-thirds of the cost
and the second element of the cost is
the fact that by retiring earlier and
not working for a couple more three four
more years we're not receiving
contributions on the pay they would have
received if they had continued working
to the age that they were allowed to
retire under the law before the service
purchase in the last element of the cost
is a risk premium
that is built into uh at the
recommendation of our actuaries Gabriel
Roeder and Smith
the risk premium is an additional 20
percent
and it is to account for three elements
and that is uh
investment performance
payroll experience and changes in
Actuarial assumptions such as
demographics
um and that that is basically how we've
come up with it the statute required us
to charge the full actual variable value
actuaries and this is what they
recommended
and it was adopted by the board
okay thank you uh
when I looked at it it appeared that by
buying service they also bought
themselves a larger pension because
they the stair step was from Two and a
half percent to two percent of salary so
that
even if they only bought one year they
were buying themselves a larger pension
I'm not sure what you mean by entire
period but I will say that the law
provides that the multiplier for the
year used for the years you purchased
will be 2.5 your remaining years are
calculated based on where you fall in
that tier
uh but the additional years it's it's
not for you you aren't buying yourself
up to 2.5 for the 10 years in between no
okay just for the one to four years you
purchase would be calculated at 2.5 and
this is one of the elements that
challenged us technically to change our
system because our system uses the same
multiplier over the whole career of an
individual this now would require us to
have certain years at one multiplier or
another year is that are different so
there was a lot of a technological
challenges and program involved okay
well thank you that explains it to me I
think any does anyone else have a yes
representative Schmidt then
question
so I've been at this game for a number
of years as you know and we this is
sounds very similar to the
situation that we had back in the past
as you alluded to I think
and but we did Away With It about
10 or 12 years ago I think because it it
was not actually Equitable for the
system it was costing the system more
than the people who are buying into it
were actually paying
um and according to what I've heard you
say it seems like you've figured out a
uh a calculation that actually does pay
for itself in a way that does not harm
the system am I correcting that uh
understanding yeah if you're referring
to the short-lived program that allowed
members all members to buy up to five
years of service the methodology I
believe was based on contributions in
that in reality turned out to be
uh underestimating the actual cost and
the program only was in existence for a
year or so
um
this bill I believe originally was
proposed with a contribution methodology
of calculation which would have had the
member pay the combined employer and
employee rates
but I can say during
um
deliberations of of the legislature that
was changed to full Actuarial cost
because the other method according to
our actuaries would have come up about
12 million dollars short
by their estimates and so it was
switched but I can say that
for example we've had 137 people apply
so far
and
if it for the police that have applied
there's 103 of them
if they had
been charged based on the contribution
method as the bill was originally
introduced it would have been
45.43 of their prior 12 months
conversation the Actuarial method on
average for the individuals who have
applied so far is 46.72 so about 1.3
percent higher with the Actuarial method
than under the contribution method as
originally proposed so there isn't a
significant difference between the two
methodologies at this point on the
average but for particular individuals
who have high compensation and are very
close to retirement their percentage
cost is going to be higher because
they're retiring sooner and they make
more money
if the contribution method on average is
very similar but it would have spread it
across the whole board across the board
such that members
who were retiring earlier are being
subsidized by members who were retiring
later and to the extent that subsidy
wasn't sufficient then the employer
would be subsidizing any shortfall in
the cost
so our actuaries felt that The Prudent
course of action was to look at the
demographics in the Actuarial
considerations of this particular cohort
of members of which there were I believe
1824 potential members who would be
eligible for this benefit that
represents about
3.75 of our active membership in total
and so the Actuarial assumptions look
particularly at the individuals and just
by definition if someone is buying one
year and is now able to retire on
November 1st instead of November 1st
next year that person's cost is going to
be more because it's closer in time and
so you can see that the percentages vary
from as as low as uh 35 percent to as
high as 70 percent depending on the
individual's situation we feel that's a
more accurate cost because it's being
assessed to the individuals
to whom the cost is attributable rather
than an average basis across the whole
population of people who are eligible
that certainly does sound like the
Equitable way to do it you shouldn't be
getting more than you're entitled to or
less if you're entitled to but the
concern consideration and the concern we
had at the time the change was made was
that it was not Equitable for the system
the system was wind up being harmed
sounds we have some very experienced
members so I hope this will be pursued
by some of them who have questions thank
you very much thank you representative
I have a couple and I'll start with
adherence let's say to the statute there
strict interpretation of this piece of
legislation until you get to a couple of
points I.E we'll start with the
installed payment portion
which it appears the retirement system
is unwilling to comply with
as I've been told after making multiple
requests up there as to what that
payment method is going to look like I
was told the retirement system is not
interested in implementing that portion
of the statute is that still true
yes the board has uh determined not to
exercise this discretion under the
statute to allow for installment
payments the only service purchases for
which we do allow installment payments
are what we call employer oversight
which is when an employer fails to
enroll someone when they're first hired
um
one of the or the biggest barrier
or obstacle to installment payments is
the fact that if someone comes in and
buys a year and retires on 11-1
over what period of time you have to pay
for it before you retire
and if we were to give someone an
installment payment for his four years
and you retire 11-1
well we're not going to give you the
increased benefit until four years later
when you're finished paying now we've
got to go back and recalculate and give
you the money
uh that you owed now that you're fully
paid it just wasn't as feasible
to have an installment payment for
people who by definition are applying
for this to retire sooner rather than
later although I will say that um many
of the members that have applied a
particularly those who are requesting
the full four years still have quite a
few years to go even with the fort to
retire
um but it was the board's determination
that in installment payments uh
weren't as feasible in this situation so
we uh they decided not to exercise their
discretion
I think one of the things that you we're
also looking at here from understanding
what you're telling me is that you're
looking at the employee portion the
employer portion the uaal portion and
then you're slapping a 20 penalty on top
of all of that
now that is certainly as you've alluded
to different
than what was done in roughly 12 years
ago that is not how that was calculated
in any way
and I don't recall a single discussion
in either the house or the senate in
reference to
this being done in a different manner
than it was done
12 years ago so this this came as a is a
big surprise to me but just so just so I
can get the clarification here the uaal
employer penalty is part of the
calculation you're using to determine
what someone has to pay for a year of
service
uh no I think you're mixing apples and
oranges uaal is a portion of the
employer contribution attributable to
the underfunding employer con
contributions in general are split into
two categories
the amount needed to fund the
underfunding and the amount needed to
pay for the annual accrual of this
year's benefit the normal cost the
member contributions make up about 75
percent of the normal cost the employers
pay the other 25 percent of the normal
cost in the employer contribution
uh pays for all of the underfunding it's
a underfunding in the uaal is a
contribution
based concept
this calculation is not based on
contributions it's based on the
Actuarial value in other words we
calculate what is your pension now
what will your pension be after you
purchase it
calculate the present value of each of
those and the cost is the difference
that is to which that is the number on
which the premium is applied it has
nothing to do with the uaal which is a
contribution concept it has to do with
that what is the difference what is the
difference in the present value of a
member's benefit before and after the
purchase that's the dollar number
against which the risk premium is
assessed okay follow-up
so if if that's the case I've seen I've
had people send me pictures of the
letter they got back from the retirement
system indicating the the dollar amount
per year some of which are well into six
figures
and looking at what an Actuarial
diagnosis of someone looks at lifespan
and other things as you know when you
got how old you are when you got in the
system those sort of things
and doing some quick math on those it
would be impossible impossible for the
member to break even in their lifetime
what is being charged to them for this
so there's no way that you're going to
pay for something to which you will
never break even that doesn't that's
that doesn't pass a sniff test with me
yes representative Pearson I think that
it'd be fair to say that it would only
break even if the person were to live as
long as they were expected to plus the
risk premium so yes if you're
uh it it shouldn't be cheap and when we
discussed it we said this is going to be
expensive and everyone agreed sure but
I've seen numbers as high as 125 000 per
year which is atrocious atrocious
to charge someone representative Pearson
do you have a question or is this a
speech
I'll get to the question part thank you
please do
do you think and is it of the opinion of
the board of the New Hampshire
retirement system that the idea was for
these members to purchase something to
enter into retirement having to fully
mortgage a home and to go into massive
debt just to Simply get out when they
were promised originally
oh I can't speak to the intent of the
board I can speak to what I know and
respectfully I think your math is
incorrect
in fact two-thirds of the cost would be
recovered in the additional pension that
the member would receive by being able
to retire early one to four years
depending on how many they purchase I'll
give you one example there was a member
who was concerned about the cost
he would he would recover
two-thirds of his cost in the first year
he was retired his benefit would then be
increased monthly after that such that
after eight years of retirement he would
have recovered his full cost the basic
design of it is you are paying for an
additional benefit so that over the life
of your retirement your cost will equal
the extra benefit on a present value
basis
um so it it is it is categorically
untrue that it's impossible for someone
to recover the money in fact
mathematically it is designed and when
the the only people in my view that
wouldn't recover the money are those who
die earlier than their life expectancy
so one last question in reference to the
103 people that applied those are people
that applied how many actually agreed so
far to to the terms that were laid
forward to them a handful because we
just finished uh our programming and
I've just started to be able to
calculate and send out bills and and
actually process in the system the
payments and so I can't I can't it I
checked with staff this morning she said
about five or six but we didn't have
stats on that okay thank you
representative leckis and then Allegra
thank you
um first part of my question was
answered about the uaal
um
but what I will ask is I understand
depending on how close someone is to
retirement their salary and I'm sure
other factors how much they would have
to pay is going to vary but uh
can you provide like two or three kind
of scenarios that cover that range what
their circumstances are and what it
would cost for them to buy additional
years
um I can't speak to any
individuals you know particularly but I
can say that generally
um one example is there's a corrections
officer through a tremendous amount of
overtime made 250 000 last year and and
she wanted to buy four years and the
cost is almost four hundred thousand
dollars because she has such a high
salary she's buying four years and
that's that's what it costs the cost is
what the cost is
um really what we're discussing here I
think is who's going to pay that cost
um so the cost is the number and that's
what it is and if
um if you were to reduce the cost for
the people buying it someone else has to
we've gone through a bit of a maze since
the question occurred to me a few
minutes ago so I may ask representative
Pearson to repeat the original question
but uh it occurred to me at the time to
ask is the discretion that you mentioned
uh installments I believe it's uh
representative would you please repeat
exactly what you were asking about well
um represent Allegro if if you're
referring to the installment the payment
portion that is yes listed in in the
language of the statute
um there's nothing listed in the statute
in reference to a 20 penalty there's
nothing listed in the statute about
other specific elements that the board
has chosen to do so it's like the pen
the payment part of that
because I actually had to pull it up
is in the first is in the first portion
so
it specifies that the
full Actuarial cost of service credit
determined by the actuary based on
methods and assumptions recommended by
the actuary and approved by the Board of
Trustees
and then the
pert on the
as a lump sum or
installment payments as permitted by the
board
and that gave them full discretion we
may not have upon more mature
recollection we may not have wanted to
give them full discretion but as of now
that they have this they have full
discretion the board yes
and you concur with that
I I concur with that interpretation yes
the board the statute as written gives
the board full discretion to determine
whether installment payments are
appropriate and at this point they have
decided not to exercise that discretion
for the reasons I stated earlier primary
primarily being it may not someone's
retiring soon you don't have an
installment period all our service
purchases of all type have to be paid
for before you retire thank you
okay
thank you
representative blackis
on that point was there any
consideration given that you know by the
board on
you know if people have enough years
left to permit installment in that
situation where they might not have the
complications no
thank you
and I I would just like to clarify that
the 20 is a risk premium it is a
component of the full Actuarial cost
it's not a penalty that we slap on top
there's no penalty involved here this is
a determination of the full actual cost
it has three components
The increased benefit by retiring
earlier the Lost contributions by
retiring earlier in a risk premium
to shift the risk that if the Actuarial
assumptions
are incorrect in the long term because
of differences in experience investment
performance demographics that that risk
is borne by the person buying the
service and not by the system as a whole
representative scitec
does the does the uaal figure into this
calculation no
that's what I thought I understood the
other question is this let's say in
employee a pays the 400 000 somehow
are you saying with this two-thirds
number that if that person's lifespan is
eight years that in eight years that
person will recover two-thirds of the
four hundred thousand yes in that
scenario they'll they'll start their
benefit four years earlier so they have
four years of a benefit let's say it's
they've got the 20 years of service and
their benefit is 50 of their pay or
fifty percent of 250 down that's 125 000
times four years
right there they're making back like all
any other questions
thank you madam chair so I I some of the
terms that have come up in your response
to our questions
have you know uh been along the lines of
where I was going that there are a
number of assumptions that are made uh
by the uh by the actuary and so forth
but also that by the proponents and
presumably by the opponents as well and
that's the thing I am concerned about is
if you're making assumptions uh and
either the investment uh you know
doesn't pan out as well or whatever then
you can be quite uh you know you miss
the the uh the porch you're steering for
because you uh move the tiller the wrong
way at the wrong time uh and because
this is all subject to Future
developments that are projected or
predicted that may not be real
uh I'm wondering whether we've whether
we've thought it through enough and
calculated it perhaps by the opponents
and representative Pearson has already
suggested certain aspects that seem
unworkable to him
so I I just wonder whether we've had
enough enough looks at this proposal to
see whether we're
definitely not harming the system
because if we are then everybody is
paying besides the person that has the
benefit potentially
it's inherent in any Actuarial
calculations that your underlying
assumptions may turn out not to be true
you know you you know predictions are
predictions uh and that is why we felt
that the risk premium was appropriate to
address that and assess to the
individual buying the service the risk
that those actual assumptions may not
bear over the long term yeah I would
like to comment that the
the risk of this is significant because
they're getting
the earlier retirement sooner uh right
up front rather than in the distant
future
and the people that are likely to do
this are the people that anticipate they
will be living long enough to collect a
larger pension for longer
um
that that's always a risk factor in any
retirement scenario that the long-lived
people will uh
want to get bigger pensions well I I
believe you've hit on a good point and
that is that there is an element of what
we refer to as adverse selection and
that is those who most likely to benefit
are most likely to purchase and that's
one of the minor factors uh in terms of
the other Actuarial factors
investment performance
payroll growth
demographics
we used our normal Actuarial assumptions
which are set based on our actual
studies that we do every five years to
readjust those factors for changes it's
not like we set a factor now and that's
those those are the assumptions we're
going to use for 20 years they're
Revisited every five years but based on
the currently effective assumptions
those were the Baseline that was used in
these calculations and they were tweaked
around the edges to address the
differences in this population
one of which is now you have people
retiring at 45. not 60 like the vast
majority of members so there's a longer
period of time from retirement to death
no no I'm comparing I'm comparing it to
group ones what I'm saying is
what I'm saying is the Actuarial
assumptions took into account the fact
that these members will be retiring at
an earlier age and therefore there is a
longer period of time over which
Actuarial assumptions may turn out to be
true or not true your window will risk
that your predictions are inaccurate is
longer when someone retires at 45 than
when someone retires at 60. and that's
representative fellows thank you madam
chair I I just had a short question how
common is it for pension plans to have
this option of people to buy credit
in this manner
um we're unique because our tiered
group two middle tier
for for those folks is unique
when that was put into place
um however
public plans across the country have
various types of service purchase
oversight military service purchase is a
very common one
some people allow out-of-state service
we used to allow it if a teacher from
Massachusetts came here they could take
their money out of the Massachusetts
plan and buy the time in our plan we
don't do that anymore other states do
service purchase is a very non-qualified
service purchases meaning ones that
aren't based on your actual work service
but you're buying time for other reasons
we have military service we have Peace
Corps Service we have oversight we have
prior temporary service if someone came
in and worked in a temporary job and
then became full-time they could go back
and buy the time for when they were in
the temporary position in that case the
member pays the full cost
so there are a variety of service
purchases and and we offer most of them
in other states similarly do but one
that's exactly like this no because
we're unique in our benefit structure
that way representative scitec
does oversight mean is that a synonym
for employer error yes employer
oversighted a failure to enroll at the
allow service Time by and that that is
yeah and that's based on a contribution
calculation not an Actuarial cost
that's different
matter yes yes one more element to this
and that was the intent of Senator de la
Sandra's filing of this is the fact that
I'm sorry it's not bipologist there's
one more element of this representative
fellows in the fact that changes were
made to the pension system retroactively
that that is unique to New Hampshire as
well so you have to look at the intent
here as to why representative goalie and
Senator D'Alessandro brought this
forward and that's a major element to
the to the crew the whole reason this
bill exists
yes however the bill is not as it was
originally introduced it was
significantly modified in the Senate the
house just Pat did not make any
amendments it was changed in the Senate
to to Simply require the full Actuarial
cost
which is their prerogative and whether
it's the the sponsor's intent or not
that's what the law is
correct except that she asked what are
some of the underlying elements as to
how these things come about and I just
wanted to make sure that that was a
factor specifically to New Hampshire as
to why this came about yes thank you
yes I I'm rather disappointed that the
board has
decided no installment payments under
any circumstances
and I would think that they should take
a look at that decision particularly for
people that are buying significant
amounts of time
so that you know they are planning to
have an installment payment completed
before they retire because that would be
if that's their plan we should we should
encourage them to do that because it's
not everybody can just up and write a
check for four hundred thousand dollars
right well certainly I'll bring that
back to the board and mention it uh to
our benefits committee we have a meeting
scheduled uh coming up the first week of
October I'll put that on the agenda uh
frankly there were so many moving parts
from an implementation point of view
that in order to get this in place so
that people can retire
right away if the purchase allows them
to do that we wanted to get it in place
as soon as possible is a lot of
programming a lot of administrative work
changes in processes
that were involved that
probably put aside the installment part
of it for now because that was one more
element that would have delayed
implementation
but I think you make a valid point if
someone's buying four years and that
allows them to retire four years early
but that's still six years from now
perhaps installment would be appropriate
okay thank you that is if you look at it
again representative Lucas
thank you
um
I just I I understand the reason for
some risk premium I'd be interested to
know you know the justification with the
20 number
and and how that was calculated
especially given that you know risk of
being incorrect can go both ways and uh
you know if uh the fair the several
factors you mentioned
uh ended up turning more in the uh to
the benefit of the pension fund
then you've gotten people to pay money
and and that's you know never going to
go back to them right so no so how a
little more about the details on how
that 20 was uh developed well again it's
comprised of basically three components
and that is
the investment performance that the risk
that investment performance will not be
as high as estimated and we currently
have assumed rate of return of
6.75 percent
which is fairly robust we've always met
that based on 1 5 10 20 years back we've
met our assumed rate of return
um but you don't know where markets are
going in the future the second element
of that is a payroll experience
and by that I mean built into the
assumption is
um certain uh
assumptions that
payroll growth will be x amount and
those are the contributions that will be
coming in across the board for active
employees and if payroll growth doesn't
meet that expectation that's another
risk and the third risk was just the
pure demographic risk that someone would
okay uh thanks for that I I get that I'm
just curious how they factored in
um the possibility that you know things
could go in the other direction that you
know the investment
uh the rate rate of return could be
higher than expected payrolls could grow
more than expected
right um and then the average lifespan
of the people who chose this um
we're not as long as expected so how is
it when you calculate the 20 risk
premium how is that possibility factored
in
to come up with I'm just curious how
that number came to be I understand the
factors that are going into it but I
understood
um well I'm not an actuary
and they're very complicated
mathematical formulas that they use they
run iterations and and come out with the
norm or an average that they feel is
appropriate and in this case
they recommended the 20 how they do the
underlying math I'm a lawyer
representative O'Brien thank you madam
chairman thank you for taking my
question
uh I heard you in your testimony and you
mentioned several times and you hit the
point
that and one would say probably if they
just stepped into the room that the
attention of this bill was to have
people retire early
but was it not really because where the
pension system had changed these people
had started were not yet vested at the
10 years into the particular system yes
representative O'Brien let's not rehash
10 years of history no but no but to get
to the point Thank you madam chair and I
do ask for very briefly and thank you
for your courtesy
uh but that's what really brought us
here with this because uh the thing is
so do you think when we write a bill we
may not get it 100 correct but it sounds
like we missed the mock if Our intention
was trying to uh help out the people
that were in the process when this was
uh first started would you agree with
that I can't speak to the intent of the
legislature's legislators rather but uh
my view was that the purpose of this
bill was to allow people to buy the time
so that they could retire at the same
time they could have retired prior to
the changes in law in 2012.
the further determination was that if
someone wanted to do that they had to
pay for it and it was just a question of
who pays for it and what method and
that's the full Actuarial cost follow-up
we're going to change gears here uh for
clarity I retired member of the group 2
system okay uh my last paycheck to nhr
uh New Hampshire retirement system
manage RS took out a pension payment
okay when did I actually get that money
you say there's a loss of Revenue but
when does that actually occur uh in
other words is that money that my last
paycheck that I had in my last
contribution to the New Hampshire
retirement system did not not go into
the gray pile get it reinvested and
could it perhaps make more so the less
isn't as the loss isn't as cute as maybe
perhaps what you're portraying it
I'm not sure I followed that question
sir well in other words if I can clarify
president of O'Brien yeah
the question is that a person who buys
back a year of service and retires in
2020 in 2022 instead of 2023 will not be
making payments for a year correct
okay that's the loss of contribution to
the retirement system okay but they they
are collect they do invest the money
even from your very last paycheck
and I would like to ask when in in
general a person who is retired gets
back their contributions without
interest or other growth do you know
that number well yeah when a person
retires their member account is
transferred to the state annuity account
and
um based on the form of benefit they
choose
each payment
each annuity monthly annuity payment
reduces their member account month by
month by month there's two options to do
that one is fast one is a little bit
slower
It generally takes seven to ten years
before the members account is exhausted
and from that point on the state annuity
yes forever from O'Brien yeah thank you
I would like to thank the chair for uh
clarifying the direction I was going
thank him Madam chair yes I mean that's
actually better than some because I
remember when I was working for a
company that had a defined pension
contribution
Define benefit
pension that people were recovering
their contributions in three to five
years but that was some time ago
private plans have different Actuarial
assumptions that are imposed on them by
the federal government under erisa we're
not subject to that so their numbers are
different
can't get this any closer I hope you can
hear me all right uh that seven to ten
years
to to the point where you have I guess
you would call it break even with your
contributions
uh does that apply to both group one and
group two individually or are they
co-mingled to come up with that uh just
it applies based on each individual how
much the benefit is and what the value
of their member account is which is
based on their contributions plus the
interest that was accrued to that and
the reason for that is that if someone
dies before that period of time unless
they pick the absolute maximum benefit
um
if there were re or a Survivor annuity
for a spouse if they said no I'm going
to take the second highest benefit just
for myself no Survivor annuity that's
gonna but if I die before my member
contributions are gone the excess gets
distributed to a beneficiary that I
designate so that's an option the
balance of uh the remaining
contributions on debt
that applies if you don't have a
Survivor beneficiary
thank you just quick question on that so
the amount in their account is just the
straight dollars that were contributed
for their pension um and that is that by
both them and their employer that's the
first part and second is that number
calculated uh without any uh assumed
interest on it
um that is member contributions only the
employer contributions go into the state
annuity fund the member annuity fund has
individual accounts for each member
their contributions are posted to that
account and interest is accrued and uh
applied to that account on a monthly
basis based on the assumed the lesser of
the actual rate of return of the plan
for Investments over the last fiscal
year
or six uh
two percent less than the assumed rate
of return so the range now for interest
is between zero and four point seven
world I don't see any other obvious
questions so I'd like to thank you for
the information you're welcome and I
would
mention to other people that if we have
the if the law as implemented doesn't
meet what you what the intent was
I'm sure there will be attempts to fix
it because
we often don't get the intent exactly
right on complicated things like this
I would lose leave then with this
closing note that the cost is what the
cost is and if you reduce it for the
person's purchasing it someone else has
got to pay it
yes that was the discussion we had in
this committee was that
it was a benefit for them under the
circumstances they were in to be able to
buy back some time
and retire earlier or at a larger
pension
and it would be expensive but for some
people it's worth it and so I'm I'm glad
you're able to at least get some people
started onto onto it
thank you madam
which do you have representative zaitek
when you're finished I have a comment oh
okay I think I don't see any other
questions so we do have some other
business we're going to vote out some of
our retained excuse me interim study
bills that we've completed the study on
uh so thank you very much Mr Kavanaugh
representative Saitek you have a comment
yeah I do this is an old comment rule me
out of order or stop me I'll try to keep
it short we've I want to blow a lot of
the technical foam off this beer and get
to the underlying equities it is just
for me it has always been wrong to pull
the rug out from a police officer who
had six years to go six months to go and
the whole thing's changed there this is
the danger of having Cliffs instead of
ramps where things taper off the room
would be empty if we had that the other
part is I think the state
somehow should accept some
responsibility or some measure not the
retirement system but we're forgiving a
hundred dollars electric bills whatever
it is we can help this middle tier
because we have quote improved the
system and in the meantime ground up the
middle tier and that seems that I'm
willing to pay that price of helping
them out it's this is old news and I'm
done
thank you anyone else
okay
all right does anyone who had an interim
study have a motion I'd like to move on
House Bill 1395 which was revising the
gel car process
that it's not recommended for further
legislation
okay
yeah and I'd like to say that the plan
in the bill as written is totally
unworkable and some of the concepts that
we thought about
can be implemented without legislation
so we can check it out and see if it see
if it does work and I plan to do so in
the next year I don't think we need
legislation on this issue
representative Schmidt
okay
does anyone else wish to comment on that
bill
okay seeing none the motion is not
recommended for further legislation and
the clerk can call the rule
um
representative gotcha thank you uh
that can make rookie mistakes no matter
how long I'm here uh representative
Rhodes yes
the clerk votes yes representative
Pearson
yes
representative yakubovich is not here
representative look leckis yes
representative Allegro
yes
representative Bailey is here
representative Lazaro yes
representing Santo nastasso not here
representative goalie is not here either
representative should yes
representative Judy no esta okay
representative Schmidt yes
representative Marsh is apparently not
here either representative fellows yes
representative flintno is still in
Rochester representative groda
yes where did she go she's hiding in the
right hands there okay all right and
representative O'Brien yes
and the chair yes
I didn't screw that one up do we need to
pray
I don't know 13-0
13-03
okay
okay anyone else rubs on the playground
we're looking to move on to the next
motion is that correct yes
um on HB 1061 I would move to recommend
for further legislation
is there a second
well I'll second it could someone please
recommend remind us what that bill is
sorry
uh yes it's been a while uh the title
please uh that's the one dealing with
Midwifery midwivery if I if I may uh on
the previous uh 1395 was that you making
recommend the yes that was the one I was
responsible for and the second was
Schmidt
okay this bill is number 1061 10 51. 61.
and
um
you you made the motion representative
legro yes I'd like to speak to that
motion very very second yeah the second
was
yourself I I seconded it okay okay sorry
I'm slowing down
representative Allegra or you wish to
speak to your motion yeah the underlying
premise I mean the subcommittee's
decision was unanimous but the
underlying premise was that uh this
should be
um within the framework of the amendment
foreign
the amendment had to do with the
um composition of the board
um the legislation originally changes so
that the midwives would be in a minority
and the amendment to restored uh one
Midwife position and it was zero nine
four eight h
okay thank you I don't have anything to
say about it
okay I don't see any other discussion so
the motion is to pursue further
legislation
and the clerk and call the roll
representative Rhodes yes
the clerk Pro TS representative Pearson
yes representative lekkis yes
representative Allegro yes
representative Bailey
yes representative LED Zara yes
representative shuitt yes representative
Schmidt yes representative fellows
yes
representative groda
representative O'Brien yes and the chair
and for those whose memory about interim
study bills
is not as good as it might be the
recommendation is simply whether we
think it deserves further legislation
and any member can bring forth that
legislation if it's necessary
so
or any other legislative yes well that's
always it's that's always true
but in but if you recommend further
legislation uh it's a kind of a good
idea to to put it in yourself
representative fellows this is just a
process question is there a report
somewhere that that says why each each
person making the motion will be sending
me a blurb on why they recommend further
legislation and that will be published
in the calendar
[Music]
sometimes or just before the election
usually
yeah the the reports are due uh usually
November 1st I think that's the time
frame still and so they would appear
sometime between that and the election
usually
yeah
yeah and
well there's not much time between
November 1st and the election it's the
eighth this year so there's a solid week
wow and and you had said uh anybody who
recommends for legislation knows you a
blurb I assume people owe you a blurb if
they recommend it the person who makes
the motion either way
the person who recommends legislation is
normally expected to produce said
legislation but if the if the
recommendation the subcommittee or of
this committee is not to offer for the
legislation I assume they're still a
blurb there's still a blurb okay thank
you I'm writing one
all right anyone else that have one that
they are they think is through Madam
chair I have one for house bill I think
it's 14 29 The Establishment massage
establishment
yes your motion
um my motion is to recommend for further
legislation
okay then moved by uh represent grota
seconded by Schmidt you do you wish to
speak to your motion yes the committee
met and um
well subcommittee met excuse me and it
was thought that the
bill could be
refined to include local
authorities and we felt that that would
be inadequate that would be important to
thank you madam chair so we had a very
active subcommittee both in terms of
members of the legislature of Edna but
and it's uh seems perfectly obvious that
this is an ongoing concern of
considerable significance in the in the
cities and towns affected such as
dairy in the meantime Merrimack I
understand uh has five or six of these
what I can refer to as massage parlors
uh and I was somewhat disconcerted to
discover that even Dover now has one
establishment
that I passed by on a regular basis on
my way to go grocery shopping it's you
would think it's just an ordinary
residence and yet this illegal activity
is going on
and and in the case of dairy I've had
several discussions with the leadership
of the talent Administration
and they are they are very unhappy with
the fact that the state has no uh has no
leverage in statute to
both license legitimate therapy massage
establishments and thereby to have a
means of going against these what I
could refer to as massage parlors which
are violating the current statute of
health and safety conditions
sanitation
food service and so forth in these
places
they could do that but the police for
example are not at all interested
because it's just a misdemeanor uh the
the employees and the establishments uh
get bailed out right away sent away
to other towns sometimes even the
management changes but the business goes
right before goes right forward and it's
just a cost of doing business for them
to pay the the uh the fines and so forth
for the misdemeanors so the police
really are not interested in pursuing
this because it's basically a waste of
their time
but the the proposed legislation would
give legitimate therapeutic massage
establishments uh some standing in some
places they're seen as equivalent or
similar to massage Partners which they
are not so it's an insult to them to
categorize them in that fashion
but that because of the clear fact that
the massage parlors are not performing
therapeutic massage the employees are
not licensed they can't get licensed to
do therapeutic massage because they
don't have any training and that's not
what they're doing
and so it would be an opportunity for
OPC to to begin to enforce
simple standards which they're somewhat
reluctant to do but after discussion
with the executive director and so forth
they recognize that this is you know a
viable means of taking some form of
action against these massage parlors so
I definitely think that any further
legislation is appropriate I mean I'm
sure if I may
the legislation merely
states that massage establishments will
be licensed this will give oplc the
authority to inspect
the businesses to see that the people
there are licensed and then and
therefore if there are issues that
require
further action the legislation says that
while the future legislation would say
that local authorities would be involved
all right anyone else have a comment
representative Rhodes
thank you thank you madam chair I I just
would like to point out that at
when we had the original hearing on this
bill it was really presented as this was
a local issue this was a local issue and
that was kind of a narrative that had
taken over in my opinion of that hearing
and then at our subcommittee hearing it
was brought out
really brought to our attention that
this is actually a Statewide situation
it is not just a local issue and the
services that are being offered really
are
light licensed Services where that was
not the case in what we found what was
really happening so I actually am am in
support after the the work session that
we had on it of future legislation thank
you
okay
I representative Bailey
my original concern was when we started
with all this was that this was kind of
a
a licensure as law enforcement as
opposed to oversight of expertise and I
haven't heard anything change really
so I would not recommend this yes
representative scitec based on my
experience in Salem which has had
exactly zero problems handling this
locally I'm going to vote against it for
that reason not because they shouldn't
be inspected but I think that it can
with respect to rep representative
and I have to agree with the last two
speakers
um
in many I don't see why all of the
hundreds of massage establishments in
the state need to be licensed because
some of the larger cities can't enforce
health and safety requirements on the
facilities in their towns and
as we as we heard Salem is not one of
them they have a local ordinance that
they enforce and they don't have a
problem so I think that the if there is
further legislation needed it is more on
the lines of clarifying that localities
have the
authority to license and inspect rather
than
having every place in the state
contribute to helping a few towns
enforce their business
Madam chair are you referring to
enabling legislation to allow local
municipalities
to perform a function that is assumed to
be a state
no I'm
going to have
authorizing legislation to have
localities enforce their health and
safety requirements restaurant
which which is I what I believe to be
representative schuette thank you madam
chair
um correct me if I'm wrong but don't the
localities technically have that right
now without
I would have thought so so what what
representative on scitec right I was
going to make a similar comment and I'm
going to vote against recommending
legislation unless uh you know somebody
brings up
evidence that dairy's operating
illegally or outside of their Authority
we have an existence proof that it can
be handled locally today and I don't
think there's a need for further
legislation
uh there is indeed I believe there is a
need for further legislation because
when I talk to our health officers he
was tiptoeing around whether he really
had the authority to do this and it
would be awfully nice to have state law
permit him to do this so I'd like to see
something here and not just not
I'd like it done I'd like to enable
local the locals like they do
restaurants
nice to representative fellows thank you
madam chair
um I have a recollection which could be
inaccurate that last term we had a bill
that had to do with
um licensing massage establishments and
and but the bill that we had had
something to do about
excluding those that were just a single
therapist
did that pass or what I'm so I'm trying
to figure out what happened here
I don't believe it passed
they couldn't have any hearings so no it
died
so as yes as a follow-up
um the subcommittee did they have any
discussion about that situation like if
we're going to license them or or they
did they discuss excluding those really
small one-person shops
those the bill that was submitted to our
original committee is the same as the
one that was submitted originally and
thank you further comments or questions
representative shewitt thank you I'll
just further point out
um
for the benefit of committee members who
may not realize that even if this does
not get recommended anyone can put the
legislation in again as a matter of fact
I've noticed that representative Broda
has like an LSR already submitted that
appears to address this issue
so I our recommendation is somewhat uh
yes it's a sense of the committee
I would never let anyone on this
committee feel that they are toothless
or hopeless
no we will it it seems that there will
be some legislation which which after
representative Rhoda is happy with it
will come to us and get thoroughly
mangled
um
exactly representative that's exactly
all right any uh other comments
no okay in that case the motion is
recommended for further legislation and
the clerk can call the Rollie
representative Rhodes yes
the clerk votes no representative
Pearson yes
Representative leckis no representative
Allegro no representative Bailey no
representative lanzara yes
representative assured yes
representative Schmidt
representative groda
yes representative O'Brien yes and the
chair no
two four six eight to five in favor of
recommended all right
I'll if anyone wished to write a
Minority Report feel free
no appetite yeah I'm not going to all
right
any does anyone else have a bill that
they think we are through studying
well don't we have to get them all
representative O'Brien no we we can't
get them all because at least one of
them representative Lucas's is yeah
although actually you know what your
recommendations
chairman my question is through the
chair to uh representative scitec uh he
did share the committee with the
building instructors inspectors are we
ready for that
do we make a decision on that
building
duplexes yes I think that Madam chair I
think that was your bill it was my
abilius
since I've already written the blurb
what's your recommendation
representative scitec
um
okay not recommended do I have a is is
there a second represent psychic
recommends not not recommended for
further legislation on House Bill 1191.
representative O'Brien oh second seconds
okay
there is a good idea here but it's would
take a lot of work that I'm not willing
maybe somebody else
well maybe someone else is but it seems
that there's
The Cure is
quite involved here uh you have the the
I have a personal problem even with
doing work in your own house you have
your own family to contend with you
don't own them and if you're incompetent
you shouldn't be allowed to do
electrical or gas work especially gas
worker electrical work you get you know
uh
so but I have putting that aside well
can I put it aside it's it's part of the
formulation of how I feel
you're doing work in somebody else in
the duplex you could affect your the
health and safe health and safety a
rubber stamp word uh of yourself or your
family that's in it by standards
bystanders to the work that's being done
in the duplex now
basically if you're competent I'm not
saying necessarily licensed I'm not sure
how you would handle a situation look
I'm competent to do this work
meaning I know when I'm over my head I
stop I get the pros but I know I'm not
going to be cutting any gas pipes and
letting the play that's just out of the
question all right
so this is just simply too complicated
to uh to try to thread the needle of a
good solution
so I
as written it should not go
can it be saved if someone wants to do a
lot of work I think it can be there's
something here as I said the path to
competence if not licensure
which should be true for anybody working
in any house
so I I it on the grounds that it's
simply too complicated to make it work
as written I'm going to not I'm going to
move I have moved that it's not not as
in this form not be recommended for
thank you madam chair uh when
representative seitzek when we held this
particular committee meetings one of the
representatives showed up whereas
members of the uh inspection services
for the individual communities and
currently right now state law basically
says if you live in a single-family home
a man's home is his castle so if if the
homeowner who lives in a single
occupancy decides to do this type of
work uh could he in the worst case
scenario jeopardize his family yes but
he wouldn't inadvertently jeopardize
what I would say the innocent and who
are the innocent I think when we go into
a situation and agree to pay rent such
as in the duplex or a multi-family home
we're at the whim in hopes and good
trust and good nature that the landlord
has done its due diligence and has done
the proper wiring and at the uh like
something as very simple as the uh hot
water system is properly vented and
everything else uh yes there is a need
and there is a lot of communities in the
state of New Hampshire that do not have
uh building inspectors and I can
understand uh the wants and needs of
this particular bill but in communities
where there's a lot of rental
occupancies uh we I felt that it did
need so therefore I supported the
committee what the recommendation not to
support this
okay
he's gonna block us
thank you
um you know well I support I supported
the original bill I'll go along with the
not recommend further legislation
because I don't see
it's likely any legislation I could
support coming out of it more than
anything else and just uh
in response to the concerns about people
doing work on their own single-family
home
uh the question is where do you draw the
line I mean does the government people
can do many things to endanger their
families from how they mow the lawn
drive the car and raise their children
and I would not accept government making
decisions on competencies
sponsor
I've come to realize the bill was too
broad but I think we ought to be looking
very hard at the places where we say
doing Plumbing work without a license is
illegal
because yes you don't want to have an
inexperienced or unqualified person
designing a complete plumbing system but
replacing a sink
there are a significant number of things
that fall under the plumbing code that
any reasonably handy person can do
safely and effectively and I think we
ought to be looking at the exemptions
rather than where they're being done
that's my my point but
well that's terrific
that makes a lot of sense okay
all right any other comments
okay representative
thank you madam chair I I'm hearing the
likelihood of some legislation coming
forward and I'm just curious
um if there's some way that it can be
crafted to allow the board to make those
kinds of exceptions
just a thought yeah it's a thought
but it depends on somebody willing to do
the work as representative sciteek said
and
I'm a little I'm booked a little heavily
this this year about letting the board
make those exceptions I think I would
like to hear the board make
recommendations to us and we put them in
law because the recommendation may be
you may turn on and off the hot water
faucet
yeah I want to they have they may have a
vested interest in for keeping their
domain smaller than we might like
um this is a tough area because they
want competent people to be able to do
stuff like this but I also understand
the need for licensing even though I'm
Wild West blah blah so this is a tough
area
all right anyone else
represent blackis yeah I'm just torn on
how to vote because it's more a message
I guess that's being sent than anything
else at this point so I'll I'll make a
decision when I vote I guess it's coming
okay now anyone else Okay click and call
the roll the motion is not not
HB 1191 is not recommend will not be
recommended for further legislation that
is the motion representative Rhodes yes
clerk votes yes representative Pearson
I should have waited uh
representative Allegro yes
representative Bailey yes
representative lanzara yes
representative assured yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative fellows yes
representative groda yes representative
O'Brien yes and the chair
no
okay
I'm gonna
not as written but uh right considering
some of these
okay anyone else uh representative
goalie and Marsh have bills and they're
not here
um
person grow to you have one or two
also
I think I has Senate Bill 230 yes but I
have no recollection of what that is
in that case we don't want to discuss it
today can we I mean our recommendation
was not to recommend but I cannot
remember
good enough for
me so I'm sorry medical spas
that's 1441.
oh 230 is body art
I'm sorry
okay I cannot I cannot remember I have
to go back oh wait I that taste this is
what I'm looking for oh no no can we
just put those two off until
we please put those two off until the
next time I promise I will be sharper
okay well I think that you probably
should be awake
yeah do I promise be way sharper
okay yeah so I don't think we have any
we should take up 1312 because we have
other bills that we can't take up
because the people aren't here so we
will have to meet once more before the
end of the month
that's October yeah
and we're meeting because we have other
things to do not because I couldn't
remember no no there's okay thank you
[Music]
we have five other bills that we had
kept in interim study and we don't have
it have someone here to make a motion on
or and have someone ready to make a
motion on any of them yeah in 1312 we
have hopefully our last meeting on the
28th of this month so we're not ready
and I will State uh representative Marsh
told me he had another commitment this
morning I think he had indicated he was
going to write a statement on 1566
because the committee should be aware
another bill did pass with this but
um obviously we can take it up when um
yeah when we meet next okay so
representative Allegro scitec and groda
owe me a short report on why we should
take the action you recommend and I'll
write one online
and
congratulations to everyone for
surviving the the primaries
representative I would like to remind
the committee that if you want to sign
in for your heavenly reward the
clipboard is up here and I have no idea
what this is for but it's a custom here
it is no cell uh no no room service it's
self-service